welcome back to the game spot stayed
here at e3 2016 I'm Lucy joined by Scott
Butterworth our esteemed editor from
your GameSpot us and Joanie from rare
who's here to show off see if these
welcome Thanks
I like to be here so you guys finally
showed off some gameplay at Microsoft's
press conference on Monday what's the
reception been like literally
unbelievable
and so that video that we created was
our fans that we got to visit the studio
three weeks ago and play the game for
the first time and it together at
regular in about a week and a half and
then have it at the briefing because I
think showing we all player reactions
playing our game and the fun and the joy
of see of Thebes is what makes our game
so special and so we really wanted to
share that with the world and we're
seeing it here on the the show floor and
even like that like even as anyone
that's cynical about that approach and
going oh it looks like it's actually
canned and then they came and play the
game and then they come back and they're
like oh yeah I was doing that all right
so it's it honestly it's been incredible
like we are humbled by the reception to
it like we're so pleased to finally be
able to to get this out there and to
talk about it and to show people the
reality of what we've been working on so
so the first few years rare has been has
been known as like the Microsoft the
Kinect studio how long you see if these
been in production and when did you guys
kind of move away from the Kinect so
Greg males the design director and he is
a rare veteran of 27 years I think he
and I kind of what's crawled away about
1820 months ago my mother too to figure
out what was next
and it was it was quite a challenge to
kind of have a completely blank slate
and and do whatever you wanted you know
and to kind of come to that and for the
first few months you feel really stupid
because you keep making the wrong
decisions or you go down one thing and
it doesn't work and eventually we landed
on this kind of shared world adventure
game groups of players go in together in
in a shared world where there's always
another sail on the horizon and all you
kind of knows that that's other players
right that's the magic of our game and
you kinda don't know what they want
right but yeah so we it was super cool
to be empowered to kind of to actually
just make anything into and also a huge
amount of responsibility because you're
making
rares next big thing right and there's
such a rich heritage and there's such a
big fan base as well that like a really
keen on kind of seeing what you're going
to do and I think we've got into our
game what makes rare game special but
we're also doing something unique and
different which is what rare has always
done feel it's kind of 30s it's got to
be a little terrifying to know that
you're inevitably gonna be compared to
stuff like banjo kazooie yeah all of
these franchises the people like really
hold close to their hearts so I mean was
that something that did that make it
harder to get started in a way just
knowing that you Reena have to like
fight against these perceptions it's
it's exciting rather than frightening I
think and like we did a kind of exercise
right at the start the project about
like what makes a rare game and there's
there's so many different the we kind of
looked through all of the history of it
and there's so many different types of
games that where's always done they've
always taken on different genres they've
they're not just like you can't put them
in a box as a single kind of type of
developer and so we did that we we asked
a bunch of the team what made it we've
made a fun little internal video kind of
with everyone talking about what they
thought was and and you know and for me
it's about doing something that's
different and unique and new and so we
were looking at what emerging trends
they were in the the industry and it for
us it was this shared world kind of
games where players exist in the game
for hours and it's all about the
interactions with other players is what
makes them so unique because and you've
also got kind of control over your roles
and and your goal and and what you want
to do so it's the freedom of that and
then the other players you interact with
means you just get these really
unexpected and like emergent occurrences
and that was so fascinating to us and we
landed that before we even picked
pirates as a theme so and then Greg's
always wanted to make a pirate game
right and there's been hints to them
throughout all of rares history and all
the Dewan games and softened and it just
seemed like the perfect fit for getting
a group of players together kind of
bonding them on a ship and then and we
want to drop players into our game and
not have a convoluted chat or real or
anything like this because but you
naturally kind of understand what you're
gonna do as a pirate right and yeah oh
there's a ship and then it's like okay
and what how do I get it moving okay so
there's probably an anchor right okay
we'll raise that and then lower the
sails and you just naturally know what
to do and then it's like where we gonna
go we're gonna go on a treasure hunt are
we gonna go and take down some other
people we just
explore are we just gonna fill the boat
with booze and musical instruments
basically go out on the partnership
right and and and you can do all of that
pirate brews booze cruise yeah certified
so that correctly the first time
so do you meet up do you is there some
kind of like Lobby system where you meet
up with your friends or is it you just
kind of you go searching for a game and
you get plopped in yeah with a bunch of
other people kind of we kind of plan all
of the above really but and it's it's
it's critical for us that players with
different kind of motivations and goals
are going to be able to crew up together
and yeah you know so if someone that
just wants to explore versus someone
that just wants to fight you know you
probably don't want to make those guys
together well put those guys together in
the crew and so you know we'll look the
the looking for group thing that was
announced at the Xbox briefing was
absolutely bang-on for us and because we
were investigating ourselves like for
the last year we've been talking about
it and going but this is critical that
you know because because we know that
playing with your friends is going to be
great yeah playing with strangers is the
challenge right and so we've done
everything we can to to bond people
together and this white drinking and
instruments are in our e3 show floor
right because when you do this is when
you get drunk together you kind of bond
and the instruments actually when you
start playing is when somebody else
starts playing it and they join together
the music sort of links off and and
you're just doing fun stuff together and
it just it's like icebreakers in a game
and then then you just start working
together cooperatively and we've seen
this with so many strangers coming in
because some people's questions like
that it's like well what if I don't have
friends was like well I don't have any
like people that want to play with me
and we're like trust us like you'll be
you'll be bonded together and so and
like I said that they're looking for
group thing is just you know we will
absolutely be utilizing for that because
it's just it's a it's the perfect fit
for our game right the platform guys
approach this if a few months ago my hey
we're doing this and we were like yeah
okay then we'll take that off the back
well yeah what is the end game so like
you and your friends you take up a
pirate ship can you like have things to
your ship make it bigger make it the
biggest baddest boat on the sea kind of
thing absolutely so like personal
customization and ship customization is
absolutely a thing both functional and
and visually so again we know that's a
big player expectation and
the mayor's are gonna become the kind of
stars of our world and what I mean by
that is that there's no black beard in
our game you know we haven't got this
legendary revered pirate in there
there's no black pearl ship but what
players do the stories they tell the
videos they share and and how they show
up in the game near community will mean
that they will become the legendary
pirates right and the legendary ships of
the world is the players that are the
stars
well they then be sort of immortalized
in the game after like huge big events
and big battles I think absolutely I
think as important is that they'll be
immortalized in our community by our
community right and like but but we've
we've had some crazy ideas around
I have almost renaming taverns in the
game as we evolved the thing based on
cool things players have done like so we
absolutely we just want to celebrate the
players and when we want to get this
into player's hands much earlier than
we've ever done before because what they
do in the game how they play is is super
critical for us and so you know with
that mind on our next goal is to go to a
beta right and we haven't set a date for
that because basically what every day at
my pick it will be wrong but we're going
to be much more open and transparent
with our community moving Harewood and
like in secret notoriously rare has been
a very secretive developer in the past
but this is we're flipping out on its
head because from this point on it's
like hey we're going to talk about what
we're doing what we're driving towards
and and then as soon as we can get that
kind of that core experience of
adventuring with your friends and
meeting those kind of key motivations
that players have you know we'll go into
that beta and then we'll just grow and
evolve and and shape this experience
based on how they're playing what
they're doing and their feedback and
everything else so completely new
approach but I believe like for us at
least but I just believe that this type
of game it's the way you have to do it
right it's not just you can't just have
a great game experience and sit there
and walk away you've got a you've got to
have this open and transparent
communication and these regular updates
to the game and everything I think that
says as important as the game itself can
it seems like it would be perfect for
the Xbox the preview program right it's
just so we aren't talking about any kind
of business model decisions or anything
that we're because we just want to focus
on the game right and and the and how we
want to bring it to people and so and
and really we just want to look at our
next goal right and so that is the beat
that's what we've gone towards that's
when the first bit on people can play
the game right and that's I think the
most important thing for players I don't
mind but from a business model
perspective we have confirmed that we're
not free to play because there were a
few kind of little rumors around last
year's e3 just for people just filling
in gaps because there wasn't any
information that we shared so we just
wanted to clarify that part of it at
least it's a full release not replay
yeah so it's it's not it's not
free-to-play that's like the only that's
the only thing I've done in committing
doing here and every now and then or
beta is the thing that we're driving
towards right so yeah I've been really
fascinating that it's such a social game
it almost makes me think of something
like journey where it's it's it's an
experience that is made by how you're
able to share it with someone else and
you're able to make it through together
so journey was one of the ones that we
were referencing quite early on in terms
of how amazing it felt just around the
corner yes suddenly there was someone in
your world and it was like what felt oh
wow you're on an adventure too and it's
like it was just seamless it was amazing
and so I like that game is just
incredible and thing is I purposefully
like when I see a game that I like I
personally don't read any previews or
even anything so I had no idea that was
a thing and I thought it was an AoE to
start with and then I was like hold on
that's a person it's reacting to me and
stuff and it was that blew my mind right
but I think we we share the same kind of
golden that we want to seamlessly have
like you know chips in your world and so
you know every time you're just standing
around and you'll just see you know
you'll see a sale appear on that Rison
or you'll go up to an island and then on
the other side there's another ship
partner like those moments that same
emotional kind of oil wow those are
players and you don't really know what's
going to happen with them that's totally
the same kind of spirit I think and like
when you know when we looked at journey
and what we wanted to bring to this
players sort of surprised you so far in
the interactions that they've had I mean
have you been watching testers or
whoever is playing the game and sort of
seen them interact in ways you didn't
expect and has that sort of Sri shaped
some of the ways that you designed stuff
in the game totally it's kind of hard to
think of specific examples but yesterday
on the show floor so we've got our build
which has kind of three ships and and
your cruiser five and so a crew got
together four people and then they
played the intersect with one of our
designers was in there with them and
they played the entire time talking like
pirates time and he was laughing so hard
he was trying to record it on his phone
via the microphone and stuff but it was
just an
like at this start this project when we
were first kind of pitching the idea
right to sell it we actually had this
kind of big wall we posted of just
things that are possible into your feeds
because we wanted to give an idea of
that it's it's kind of as much up to
your imagination as possible cuz it's
just like it's a pirate fantasy right
like whatever you think you can do in
the world you should just be able to go
and do and I look like I literally put
up just like dress and talk like a
pirate waltz playing this game was one
of the things on there and um and like
and it was kind of funny just a little
moist see that and in reality here it's
like this is it like this this is the
pirate fan so you can just go in and
kind of live it and do what you want I
think there's kind of like a childhood
connection for a lot of people when you
grow up watching you know pirate
adventure movies they you know there's
it a weird kind of joy it's it's sort of
odd given that real life pirates were
you know horrible criminals but I think
this taps into like the fun and friendly
nice side of being a pirate like the you
know Swiss Family Robinson style like
being stranded on a desert island
it's not that dark and gritty and
however thing we wanted this to be it's
it needs to be a range of tone
throughout the experience right it's not
all bright blue skies and sunny islands
there's there's a mix you know and
they're not the day and night cycle that
we haven't really had changes the kind
of the feel of the game it's almost a
relief when the kind of Sun comes up
over the horizon it makes it kind of a
bit easier to see and not as foreboding
and stuff but yeah we've always wanted a
real range of tone across our game yeah
is are there any commits there
developments of any kind or any kind of
like just framing or you know lore in
the world so we know that like there has
to be a law to the world right and there
has to be a history to it and there has
to because a lot of players love to
discover this oh yeah they love to spend
their time wandering around and piecing
that stuff together but I almost see
that as an activity in it if you know of
itself to try and figure it out right
like we're not going to do a
presentation at Comic Con about the law
of the world and spacely spoil
everything right yeah it's it's like
we'll put it in there we'll build it
into the world and give it that charm
that rare games always have but then it
will be up to players to kind of try and
piece together and get on the Wikipedia
and joint you know and try and frame
exactly what we've kind of done and why
we've done it so we feel that that's
super important but it's what players do
is going to be the stories from our game
like you know that there will be quests
and things and quests and stuff to
undertake and and
it's what the players do that is the
story right there the stars right it's
um you're not it's not some like single
campaign that everybody experience is
the same
everyone should have different and
unique experiences so how many is a
perfect-sized crew so um I guess it's
it's kind of like what we've discovered
for that thing they say the ship we have
in the DfE build is quite a big ship
right and we purposely targeted that
first of all because we knew that would
be the most challenging thing is to get
a bunch of people together and get them
to kind of cooperate and to make life on
the ship fun right yeah and so so we
target that first we feel really good
about where it's at and it that's four
or five seems to be the best
we're like for that size ship because
once you get bigger than that they they
start kind of almost just just gets
disruptive they get a bit too big it's
like when you win a big group of friends
it's kind of hard to have those
conversations right you end up you
always speak splitting into two groups
and the same thing kinda happens in the
game whereas when you've got four or
five friends around oh there's three of
us here right I consider as friends now
but even though we've only just met but
unlike the it's you just it's the right
size group to kind of to go on an
adventure together and you know and
they're kind of that the funny thing in
our original again in our original kind
of vision for this week or kind of game
raiser one of them was that like The
Goonies basically it's a basically a
group of friends going on an adventure
together in a pirate world and we even
took the team we hired out a local
cinema and got some pirate themed
cocktails made and actually took a whole
team to see The Goonies kind of early on
in the game's development a little work
with you guys but it's like that's
division for the game and it's kind of
the vision for the team why it should
just be a bunch of friends going on an
adventure and there'll be trouble along
the way and we'll have some challenges
because game development hard right but
like ultimately that's the that's what
it should be that's what games
development should be given that it's
such a social game I was wondering if
there's going to be a way for players to
communicate within the game if they
don't have a headset
yes so we we know that some players will
either not want to talk not feel
comfortable with it or maybe you know
they've got a disability and they are
like you know speech impaired or hearing
impaired so we know that we have to
deliver a secondary communication
function we haven't like specifically
landed on exactly the details of that
yet but we know we'll be delivering as
part
experience but at the same time we
believe that voice is such a powerful
tool and you know there were some issues
with it in terms of in some games
there's some toxicity and stuff and my
hard work to say and and but we believe
that Alex like we've created this really
great just cooperative experience it's
like true co-op and we're working so
hard to bond people together and give
them shared goals and shared rewards
that we can encourage much more use of
the headsets and of talking you know
that then I think people are comfortable
doing or doing at the moment what like
we believe so strongly that it's such a
great social experience like going to
the park like you don't go to the pub
and not talk right and but it's like
it's it's that's our vision for it and
so we want to encourage as many people
that that can and will to use headsets
but we know that some will will not be
able to so that's fine to you thank you
so much for joining us no release date
for the BT a but is there a kind of time
frame game no but like I said we'll be
very open and transparent with our
community from this point onwards so if
you're interested in finding out and and
finding out about our development and
not on our approach and where we're
going
it's like sign up or to you know to see
if thieves on Twitter or come to our
website and sign up for email updates
because you know those are the people
that care the most you know the people
who are going to sign up for the people
that care the most and those the people
we kind of want to be talking to
regularly from our studio with our
community team and and you'll get a good
idea of where we're heading towards you
know but like I said there's I don't
think there's any point in me listening
a timeframe or anything else because it
will just move and be disappointed and
you know we don't want that right we
just want to be we just want to be
truthful and open open awesome thank you
so much guys for more coverage from this
year's e3 make sure of course you stay
tuned to games.com you're watching the
GameSpot stage brought to you by
airheads bites
you